didn't George once say that he felt he
was Tyrion yes yeah definitely I
definitely see that definitely would see
that hey youtubers it's Charlie and they
just announced this year's Hugo Award
winners and since some of my favorite
sci-fi and fantasy stories were battling
it out for awards I thought it'd be
really fun to do a video seriously Game
of Thrones and Doctor Who both went up
for the same award isn't that cool so
first I'll talk about the winners and
then I'll tell a few cool stories about
the award ceremony so here's the list of
winners best novel red shirts by john
scalzi I've actually read this and it's
totally awesome I totally agree that he
should have won best novella the
Emperor's soul by Brandon Sanderson best
novel it the girl who went out for sushi
by Pat Cadogan and best short story mono
no aware by ken loo best related work
writing excuses season 7 best graphic
story saga vol 1 by bryan cave on and
Fiona staples I've actually read this
you totally need to read this right now
it's amazing best dramatic presentation
long-form this is actually the Avengers
screenplay Joss Whedon one and it's not
for the movie is just for the actual
writing screenplay and i'm totally not
surprised by this just because ja sweet
has been nominated for an Emmy before
for his writing best dramatic
presentation short form is actually the
Game of Thrones episode Blackwater Bay
that was written by george RR martin so
there's no surprise there but this was
actually the category that it went up
against doctor who at I'll talk more
about that after I list the rest of the
winners best professional artist John
pikishi oh he actually illustrates a lot
of John Scalzi spoke remember he won
four red shirts so you need to check out
some of his stuff it's amazing he
totally deserves this best semi-pro zine
Clark's world best fanzine sci-fi signal
I actually used that website to look for
new recommendations on sci-fi and
fantasy stories so you should check it
out it's really cool best fan writer
tansy rayner Roberts best fan artist
scale antara and the winner of the john
w campbell award for best new rider was
actually murdered Lafferty for 1963 the
argument against Louie pest or now let
me know you think about all the winners
this year which of their stories have
you read and which are you going to read
after this basically like I try to look
at this as a guy for stories that maybe
I should be reading that I haven't read
before or authors that I really need to
check out the really cool thing about
this game of thrones versus Doctor Who
battle was that doctor who was actually
nominated for three
these separate episodes it was the
angels take manhattan asylum of the
daleks and the snowman remember that was
the Christmas special from last year
I'll be sure to post all these winners
as well as all the people that got
nominated on my tumblr so you can look
for all the books and stories that you
need to check out it was actually a
really cool Nerdist podcast recently
with george RR martin it was about an
hour long i'll post that to my tumblr
too he talks a lot about Worldcon and
the hugo awards in that what george RR
martin said in that interview about
worldcom is really cool he said that
they've really tried to keep it really
small and they've held the hugo awards
there even though other conventions like
san diego comic-con have gotten so much
bigger just to give you an idea he said
worldcon attendance is closer to like
4,000 people and san diego comic-con
last year was maybe like 150,000 people
so even though there are bigger
conventions it's still a big tradition
to have the hugo awards at world con and
isn't it cool that george RR martin
still goes every year if you really want
to help me out please like and share
this video and like i said i'm posting
that first game of thrones season for
character preview for Tyrion later today
to be sure to let me know which
characters you want to talk about first
and I'll try to add those people to the
top of my list too you can click here to
get that video right now and you can
click here to get all my other Game of
Thrones Season 4 videos from this year
so far thanks so much for watching high
fives congrats to all the Hugo Award
winners
you